what's up guys i'm dave klein aka dave
control and here are 10 more things you
may not have known about alvin ring as
the game has been out for a while now
i'll be getting into more spoiler
territory so you have been warned
invisible platforms number one if you
find both halo tree medallions you'll be
able to access the grand lift of rolled
into a secret area this area being the
hidden path to the haleg tree it may
seem pretty straightforward and a way to
get out into a newly accessible area of
the mountaintops of the giants however
your beast eye will quiver here and
hopefully clue you in on the fact that
there may be more than meets the eye
when it comes to the hidden path to the
haleg tree in fact it's actually a minor
dungeon and you basically just walked
right into the middle of it exploring
for a while i was pretty baffled and
then i realized
sometimes from software likes to include
not only luxury walls in their games but
entirely invisible platforms you can
walk across so if you go to the middle
of the staircase here you can fall off
and onto an entirely invisible platform
from this drop you'll have two ways you
can go to the left side is a clearly
visible opening in the wall so head over
here and you'll actually be able to find
an illusory wall with a silver scarab
talisman behind it this talisman will
raise your item discovery
meanwhile for traveling directly across
not much here but you can use this and
another opening further down as a guide
for where the platform exists and where
you can walk travel along this further
down and you'll find another opening and
the rest of the dungeon and even a stray
mimic to your boss with a death route
located behind them
rainbow stones speaking of these
invisible platforms there's a really
good way to test for them and find them
i'm talking about the various rainbow
stones you'll pick up and be able to
craft in the game as you can see here i
actually dropped one in the hidden path
to the haley tree dungeon to test out if
there was a platform and sure enough
that's what clued me in on it
but they're not just good for finding
hidden platforms according to their item
description ruined fragment that has
undergone some simple processing can
also be dropped to gauge the distance of
a fall the higher the pitch of the sound
the higher the likelihood of the fall
being fatal
so drop one of these bad boys and you
can test to see if the rainbow stone
makes a high pitched noise and shatters
which will tell you that you won't
survive the fall yourself
arrows for platforms
as this is an illusory themed episode
let's talk about arrows arrows are great
you can pretend you're legolas and shoot
foes from afar even while riding torrent
or you can be like me who has a melee
build and reserve your arrows for
drawing enemies one at a time so you
don't get ambushed by too many at once
there's also another use for them as
arrows stick to the ground you can use
them like rainbow stones to test for
invisible platforms this comes
particularly in handy for the next
invisible platform i'm about to show
invisible platforms number two
if you reach the mountaintops of the
giants you may just have found the
heretical rise and ask yourself how in
the world do i get into this thing the
hint tells you falling snow marks
something on the scene so clearly
there's something invisible here
but where
well you'll actually need to travel a
bit away from the heretical rise in
order to properly access it travel to
the freezing lake site of grace go up
and past the graveyard and head to the
area on the map that looks like a broken
bridge when you find this broken bridge
as it turns out maybe it isn't so broken
it's actually an invisible platform the
platform isn't so straightforward though
it actually curves around quite a bit
and will even have you twisting around
and traveling upwards so you'll
definitely want something to help guide
you along
and while the rainbow stones are great i
found the best way to do this was by
shooting arrows in front of you and
around you in order to see where you can
go
so make sure to stock up on arrows
before you head here eventually you will
find fog on the path that makes it
obvious but that's not immediate and
takes a while to get to you'll also
really want to do this if you're an
achievement hunter because the sorcerer
you get at the heretical rise is the
founding reign of stars which is a
legendary sorcery you'll need for an
achievement
item categories
i think i've talked about hidden
platforms enough for one episode so
let's talk about some minor mechanics
the first is pretty likely you'll have
noticed but if not it'll save you a lot
of time when you pick up an item there's
a category you'll see at the top left
every time you pick it up this icon is
the same icon and category as where
you'll find it in the menu so if you
haven't noticed yet this will help save
you a ton of time finding and checking
out what you just picked up item
organization
and speaking of quick ways to find items
you picked up you can reorganize your
inventory and sort items in a variety of
ways while in your inventory hit l3 and
choose how you want it organized one
such option is last item found which
will vastly reduce your time scrolling
and searching as you get further in the
game and have massive amounts of items
not losing runes upon death did you know
there's a way to not lose your runes
upon death i hope you've been paying
attention to your flask of wondrous
physic because there are some really
good tears here you'll get for them as
you explore
one of these is the twiggy crack tier to
find it you'll have to head up onto the
altus plateau and reach the capital
outskirts minor archery it's located
here on a map and as it turns out this
particular minor archery doesn't have
any urgery avatars guarding it so you'll
just have to find the chalice next to
the minor archery and within it you'll
find the twiggy crack tier and crimson
crystal tear the twiggy crack tier is
incredible by putting it in your flask
of wondrous physic the resulting
concoction prevents one's runes from
being lost upon death
however the effect lasts only a short
time it really isn't that short though
in fact for most boston couchers i found
that unless it's a super long encounter
the effect lasts for pretty much the
entire time so put this in your flask
and definitely use it right when you
walk into a boss chamber and you won't
have to worry so much about losing your
runes upon death then needing to
regather them pumpkin head's helmet this
one is a minor detail but kind of fun
did you notice that when you attack
pumpkin head hitting his giant helmet
actually makes a different sound than
when you hit his body
i know it's nothing earth shattering but
it's still fun the ultimate finger
maiden husk you can find the finger made
and husk at the round roundtable hold
this kind of npc acts as a merchant and
you can purchase various items from the
husk throughout the game you'll find
various bell bearings with some of these
being useful ones you'll find in
dungeons for example in the lyria
dungeon raya lucaria crystal tunnel
located here on a map for defeating the
crystalline boss you'll get the smithing
stone miners bell bearing one if you
give it to the finger maiden husk you'll
now be able to buy smithing stone ones
and smithing stone twos and if an npc
dies for example right here i found
brother corn dead you'll get their bell
bearing and therefore be able to still
purchase anything they sold by giving
this bell bearing to the husk however
with this in mind there's a way to give
yourself the ultimate shop all in one
convenient place
it is a truly evil thing to do so i'm
telling you right now that my co-worker
who told me this is evil and do not
trust him with anything because he is a
monster
what you can do
is any time you meet a merchant go ahead
and murder them for doing so you'll
receive the merchant's belt bearing
which you can give to the finger maiden
husk and now have access to their entire
catalog of wears right here in the round
table hold do this with every merchant
you find and you'll now have the
ultimate shop just don't do this you
monster okay i'm done trying to convince
you
the abductor virgin talking to patches
and leonia he'll clue you in on this
because he's such a swell guy patches
will hint that this will take you to the
base of the archery because he's patches
of course he's not entirely wrong here
the abductor version can be found by
jumping on the water wheel at the
academy of real lucaria and letting it
take you all the way around then drop
you at the bottom if you let the
subductor virgin grab you and kill you
with its grab it will transport you to
the volcano manor you can access this
part of volcano manor without being
abducted but i find this interesting
because it's actually something i
originally missed as i happened to kill
the abductor virgin without being
grabbed
and had completely forgotten by then
about patch's uh
advice by being transported to volcano
manor you'll be completely stuck in the
dungeon and have to work your way out
and your reward for doing so a boss
that's not one but two abductor versions
from soft at it again
and that wraps up 10 more things you
didn't know about eldon ring as always
let me know in the comments if there's
any interesting tidbits i might have
missed and i hope you learned at least
one new thing and i'll see you guys next
time peace